[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone pete also known as naldo
here to give you
a first look at battletoads
now the game has been out for a little
bit we just got our copy of it we got
our hands on it we wanted to get some
time playing it
so i ended up starting i played it for
about an hour an hour and a half and uh
i ended up
calling up my brother to come to see if
he wanted to do it to kind of recapture
our youth
like we used to play back in the day on
the old nintendo console and
we uh we started we got in there we
started playing it
and what we noticed was there were
so many changes i can't even tell you
um from start to finish so
let me let me go through our normal
standards of uh what we go through for
these games um so i will end the
gameplay for the end
uh as for the artistic value of the game
the graphics were very well done
uh they were very professionally drawn
out
uh the combat was very very fluid and
very very nice
it had that amazing feel for graphics
kind of kitty animation-ish
and it was very very surprising
very cool and the what i really really
liked was the
integration of the cutscenes and how it
was fluidly going from
one part to another part very very
easily
i really really liked it i thought the
that
they took a lot of the artistic portions
of it
and tried and they stepped it up because
most games right now
the artwork is kind of all right it's
not great
but that rare ended up taking it and
said we
need to make sure that this is just like
your youth and they stepped it up
so it worked out really really well so
thumbs up for them for that
now for the replay value of this game uh
it
it has a it has a replay value of it if
you wanted to continue to play it over
and over and over again
me personally i will probably not
because
this game has a board in it that
reminded me so much of my youth which is
the speed
servo it ends up putting you onto a jet
ski so
that jet ski itself when you're ending
up going on it it just reminded me of
back in the day when we were learning
about the jet ski
and playing with the jet ski on the
regular nintendo
and i had flashbacks and i was like oh
man this is gonna be horrible
and out of most of the gameplay that we
ended up having it was mostly us
on the jet ski trying to get past it
just like we normally do
and it was pretty much drove
me crazy but you know we ended up
getting it done
we got through that part and we got to
the next board um
so as for the gameplay portion of it
the combat was really really well done
the combat was really really fluid we
ended up fighting uh a boss
uh the boss was very very difficult to
go to complete it had three portions of
it
so you kind of learned little by little
and then you went from there
uh it was it was good uh not too bad
i ended up pushing through
we ended up getting through to almost
the
i think it was the fifth or sixth level
and
it felt like it still had some more to
go i really really
liked it i'm gonna see if i can try to
get some more time in it with my brother
because
it feels like that the couch co-op
portion of this is where
it's going to thrive and me and my
brother
if you're watching the video you'll see
us laughing joking
hitting each other all those basic
things that we normally we did
when we were kids just beating on each
other
yelling at each other and having a blast
and having a lot of fun with it
so it's really really nice to to have
that feels again which
which i really liked the
difficulty level of it it has three
different difficulty levels
and we picked the middle difficulty
level because we knew we knew how
difficult the original was and
it really wasn't that bad it gave us a
little bit of a push or a little bit of
difficulty
but it gave us enough that we were going
to be able to push through it and
complete it
so i really i really liked it one thing
that was a little more difficult for me
to get through
was when you ended up having to go from
zone to zone
uh it didn't give you that 100 direction
you kind of had to figure it out
so you kind of took a little bit and you
go oh okay we gotta go this way and then
we'd end up going
now as for the
the the attacks and things like that
each of the three toads had a different
type of
abilities of special attacks so you
ended up having
more animations and a lot more growth
for the characters
when the storyline comes into play the
storyline was actually
very adult a lot more adult than i was
expecting it to
and it had a lot of those underlying
humor jokes
uh that the adults would end up getting
and
i thought that was nice to have and i
thought it was funny i thought that
there was way too many of them but that
was just
you know i'm always good for a good poop
joke like i've always said but
at the same time you kind of have to go
through it a little bit
uh and kind of weed out some of the
the blander jokes and the ones that are
more like the low front low
low hanging fruit jokes if you will so
yeah so
thank you very much for taking the time
to check out this review
uh this is pete once again now though
here to give you the iron lords podcast
first look at battle toads now if you're
gonna go
check out the iron lords podcast we are
there on sundays
uh go check us out on this youtube page
hit that like and subscribe button
and if you're looking to see about any
more of our articles and reviews please
go to lordsofgaming.net
where we have news gaming and tech
articles so check us out there thank you
very much
bye-bye
i'm getting ptsd right now so bad
sweaty
oh great thank you
turbo back rentals my sensors indicate
you're driving like a bat
outta here dang it if you don't slow
down i'll have my sons post nasty rumors
about you on the galactic
internet they're handsome boys but
they're mean it's dirt
will embarrass you hope it doesn't come
to that
i wasn't launching
i was like do we have our other guy back
and i look up there's a whole thing on
the ground
oh god
gonna need another energy drink there
you go
so hit that last one you got it though
uh
forward
thank you
oh
wow
uh
ah
them
um
thank you very much
is
oh boys
cutting the fingers off of my gloves
guys
i'm gonna need another zip blitz oh you
back you go back
no no
i'm gonna chug music
i need a whole case of zip blitz i got
some hacking today
[Music]
is
but you're the one getting popped
all right
[Music]
you